je rentre de vacances je suis allé aux
états unis d'amérique pour la première
fois je suis allé sans mes parents
1 s'il ya une petite différence entre
partir avec ses parents et partir par
ses propres moyens
spécialement quand tu rentre de vacances
bon eh bien ce mois ci on va manger des
lots d'ailleurs j'ai un petit peu fin ça
va mieux et avant même de partir j'ai pu
découvrir peut-être la meilleure
invention des américains le est à rien à
voir avec comment est un alien
le est assez le formulaire avec des
questions bizarres qu'elle était obligée
de répondre pour aller aux états unis tu
peux faire ça sur internet maintenant je
pensais qu'il n'existait que dans les
one man show les trucs comme ça mais non
j'ai pu répondre à leurs questions
bizarres
avez-vous autrefois est impliqué dans
des activités d'espionnage ou de
sabotage de terrorisme de génocide ou
entre 1933 et 1945 avez vous participé
de quelque façon que ce soit à des
persécutions perpétrés au nom de
l'allemagne nazie ou de ses alliés que
je réfléchisse un peu
qu'est ce que je faisais en 1933 mois
déjà
j'étais vous qui sur cette planète va
répondre oui à cette question m'explique
à part pour déconner peut-être et encore
je suis pas sûr que ce soit super super
bowl les états unis facturent l oignon
et merde comme on dit c'était une blague
on oublie 10 blague blues black blue
clara jobs a joke
oui parce que c'est mieux d'aller aux
états unis quand tu sais parler anglais
ah bon moi par exemple je parle
l'anglais jeu vidéo yes no new game try
again c'est pas trop ça un truc que je
savais pas en france par exemple on dit
voulez-vous un coca cola a lieu aux
états unis ont dit
do you want to cook si je veux de la
coke ou là ce doit être un piège
d'américains savent asie réponds non
nous allons te coca cola et ouais tu
m'auras pas d'ailleurs en parlant de
coca cola j'ai une petite question pour
vous les américains petite question
comme ça c'est quoi votre problème avec
les boissons dans les fast-foods là-bas
impossible de commander un verre de vin
un tonneau
j'avais demandé à small mais c'est un
small oui c'est quoi un large alors une
piscine municipale une piscine
municipale de coke et qu'aux states ça
existe et comme tout bon français qui se
respecte et qui va aux états unis j'ai
participé à notre petit rituel
je suis allée acheter un jean levi's
voilà c'est normal en france ça coûte
quoi le moins cher c'est 90 euros moins
cher aux etats unis c'est protocole à 39
$ ça fait 27 euros attendez laissez moi
calculé ça fait à peu près trois fois
moins cher pour le même jean on se fout
de ma gueule
littéralement franchement j'ai adoré les
états unis
par contre le mec qui a inventé le métro
new yorkais est quelqu'un de syndics qui
aime faire du mal aux gens et faire des
labyrinthes à new york il ya des
stations de métro qui vont que dans un
sens si tu veuilles dans l'autre sens
devait faire un demi-kilomètre limite
prendre le taxi pour aller dans la bonne
station de métro et à new york c'est pas
une rame égale une ligne de métro north
c'est trop simple ça c'est un truc de
parisiens ça à new york t'attend sur le
quai mais tu sais pas quel métro va
arriver le cea le tu sais pas c'est la
surprise passée lequel oui non oui non
et quand tu es dans le bon sens dans le
bon métro excusez moi s'il y en a eu
oui qui va vers le sud oui merci par
contre c'est la venue exprès il s'arrête
qu'au terminus comme blaireau la ligne
express sans excès c'est tellement plus
marrant de faire des métros qui sautent
des stations pourquoi
la part ça j'ai adoré les états unis ne
vous inquiétez pas un bon j'ai un petit
peu de mal avec le décalage horaire
encore mais à peine 19h30
c'est l'heure des chocapics ça fait
quand même du bien
1 deux semaines complètement déconnecté
aucune nouvelle de l'extérieur fizaine
pour plus à la sortie de l'aéroport en
rentrant avec m'a vendu 2 places pour le
concert d'amy winehouse moitié prix
c'est une affaire en plus d'être un gros
concert j'ai vu sa tête sur tous les
magazines people que vous êtes jeunes
ils sont je le voudrais aussi d'être
aussi nombreux sur ma page facebook qui
retrouve que deux vidéos sur cyprien
point fr merci avoir marqué face à lui
[Musique]